Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa.
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
I'm not Mococo, I'm Koyori!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today, we're your hosts, FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you!
Thank you Ruffians, thank you Joshiko, thank you everyone for joining us today for a very special 90th episode!
So excited!
Thank you!
Happy!
How do you feel, Koyori-senpai, being a first guest of FUWAMOCO Morning?
FUWAMOCO Morning de hajimete no gesuto narande, kimochi wa... First guest!
I'm unbelievable!
Koyo de ii no?
Of course!
Ya, mochiro desu!
Koyari-senpai has Asakoyo on Morning Show!
Morning Family!
Morning Show Family!
Yeah, Koyori-senpai is, I'm morning senpai.
I do Asako yo.
Because I do Asako yo.
FUWAMOCO-chan, FUWAMOCO Morning, I'm happy!
Debut!
Debut time!
We're so happy to have you two calling all this support!
Thank you very much!
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
Usually it's hosted by FUWAMOCO, but today it's all three of us, FUWAMOCO-ya!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag "hashtag FUWAMOCO Morning"!
Oh, Moco-chan, you want a big BAU BAU?
One moment.
Let's all BAU BAU to FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Moco-chan big BAU BAU!
It's so much fun with Koyori-senpai here.
Thank you!
No, no!
Thank you very much!
I have some bad news.
No, no, no bad news, no.
No bad news.
Why?
There's been another peron sighting!
Slow pain?
Pero's nasty.
Pero, Koyori, BAU BAU?
Is Pero scared?
Maybe Koyori-senpai is BAU BAUing.
Pero is running away.
Koyori-senpai is a coyote.
Maybe Pero will run away from Koyori-senpai.
Let's see where Pero is.
De-den!
Cute!
Cute Pero!
Well, you know, I think maybe this Ruffian thought they were gonna have a nice cappuccino, but... No.
It was Pero!
I don't know how I feel if this was the drink I received, but the barista probably put a lot of their heart and soul into it, but I don't know.
I feel like something kind of nasty got accidentally added to this drink.
But Koyori-senpai!
Do you like cappuccino?
I love cappuccino.
PAPUCCINO!
Because they're canines, I guess PAPUCCINO!
Not PELOCHINO!
PAPUCCINO!
Do you want to drink this PELOCHINO?
Cappuccino art?
Oh, I love it!
Cappuccino art!
FUWAMOCO-chan art.
I want to do a lemon mibare.
Afraid.
I want Koyori-senpai's design on my cappuccino then.
Moco-chan, you wanna be BAU BAU?
Okay.
BAU BAU!
Maybe this cappuccino, this Perroccino, maybe this is the good kind of Perroccino.
Yeah!
Well, since Koyori-senpai is our guest today, we had a question for her.
Right, Moco-chan?
A question?
Yeah!
Well, FUWAMOCO, you know that we're kind of picky eaters, and we don't like tomatoes, and we don't like onions, and that kind of goes for mayonnaise too.
Oh!
Mayonnaise?
Mayonnaise!
So we wanted to ask Koyori-senpai What's the yummiest way to eat mayonnaise?
The yummiest way to eat mayonnaise?
Mayonnaise
Beginner?
Beginner is first mayonnaise.
Curry rice with mayonnaise.
Have you tried it?
No, we haven't tried it.
I thought you know sometimes people put on their curry rice teriyaki sauce.
I thought they had it at other places, but maybe not.
But the stores, they don't have mayonnaise.
Do you bring your own mayo to the restaurant?
I am a childhood.
Childhood?
Childhood.
When you were a child.
Yeah.
Mochiaruiteta.
I give up.
Give up?
You got it.
I eat mayonnaise.
But mayonnaise.
Mochiaruku.
I take mayonnaise.
Yeah, take it.
Kusarisou.
Oh, it goes back.
That's my Insta.
Hey, Mayonnaise Bridge!
Did they bring you mayonnaise?
Staff-san.
Yes, yes, yes!
Mayonnaise!
Is this it?
Yes!
Mayonnaise is a must item.
That's a must item.
Like ketchup!
In Japanese.
By the way, Koyori-senpai, do you like ketchup?
Ketchup, I like.
But the one you put on ketchup, I usually put mayonnaise on it.
I see.
So instead of using ketchup, Koyori-senpai, you use mayonnaise.
Omurice.
Potato fries.
Fries too and omurice.
All mayonnaise.
Wow!
Can you imagine?
If we have ponzu mix and mayonnaise!
Ponzu mix!
Mayonnaise!
Pon-de-ring!
No, no, not with mayonnaise.
But delicious.
Right?
Delicious?
Yeah.
I sort of want to try now.
I want to try pon-de-ring and mayonnaise.
I want to try pon-de-ring and curry.
Pon-de-ring and curry!
Pon-de-ring is a bit like rice.
I have another question.
Koyori-senpai, you said you were worried about it going bad.
Does Japanese mayo go bad?
I heard that in Japan, you don't need to put mayonnaise in the fridge.
Not in the fridge.
OK, but summer is too hot in Japan.
That makes sense.
I see.
In winter it's OK.
OK, OK, OK.
Thank you, Koyori-senpai, for your mayonnaise wisdom!
I want to eat mayo now.
Drink!
Drink mayo!
Mayonnaise is drinking!
It's a drink?
Okay.
Mayo choo-choo!
Giving kisses to the mayonnaise too!
Okay, today's FUWAMOCO your morning has mayonnaise kisses.
Okay?
Mayonnaise kisses!
BAU BAU!
We also had a question.
Koyori-senpai.
Why is today not a sleepover?
Why is there no youbai party?
Good.
Why isn't there a sleepover?
Why isn't there a youbai party?
We had that question.
I don't have bed.
I have only single bed.
Ah, then FUWAMOCO will use your bed and Koyori-senpai can sleep on the ground.
FUWAMOCO will sleep in Koyori-senpai's single bed, but Koyori-senpai will sleep under her bed.
That's fine, because she's a dog!
No, no, no, no, no!
Boss dog!
You are a dog too!
We're dogs too, but...
No, no, no, no, no!
No!
Kaere!
I want to give to Pajama Advent members.
All members!
So then the Yobai Party will have to wait until all of Advent's here!
And then Koyori-senpai will have special pajamas for us!
Well, we'll have to hope they're not yabai pajamas.
Yabai pajamas for the Yobai Party.
The pajamas Koyori-senpai will be giving away aren't yabai pajamas, right?
I'm not sexy!
I'm Fuwawa!
Are you sure about that?
Are you sure you wanna be saying that?
Is this a question to ask us?
Doggy Pack!
How is it?
Maybe that will have to wait until the Yobai Party with Advent.
Is it a secret until the Yobai Party?
Secret!
Look forward to it!
BAU means...
It's being so kind to give us a gift and think of all us.
I guess anything goes.
BAU BAU!
We're looking forward to it!
Next!
Konyoni-senpai!
You have something special that you'd like to share today.
Koyori-senpai has a new recent original song, Tear Gazer!
Can you talk about your original song, Koyori-senpai?
Okay, so my first maid word.
Koyori-senpai, you wrote it yourself?
The lyrics?
Yes, yes.
Koyo's heart.
It's a song that Koyori-senpai wrote the lyrics for.
You know, for times where it's kind of rough and you just don't have the energy or you just don't quite have that pump in your step.
To give you that extra push.
Yeah.
And so that you can listen to it and- It has all her feelings and heart in it.
Question!
Zettai Akiramenai is English.
Never give up!
Never give up song!
BAU BAU BAU!
Dogs are stubborn, aren't they?
That's why they never give up.
Us dogs, canine family, we're stubborn!
We're hungry!
If we wanna bite you, we'll bite you!
Bite!
Bite you?
Because we're hungry, we'll bite you!
Bite you!
Please check it out when you know maybe you're feeling a little bit like it's been a rough day.
Koyori-senpai will be there to show you it's okay.
Please listen to Tear Gazer, Koyori-senpai's original song.
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
Wow.
Koyori-senpai, you have Asakoya, your morning show.
And so, we wanted to take a page out of Asakoya's book and share a serifu.
Yeah, Asakoya lines.
Today's FUWAMOCO lines.
The first, and hopefully not the last.
Saisho wa eigo de itte mo ii kana?
Would you like Fuwawa?
Would you like Mococo?
Would you like Koyori?
No!
FUWAMOCO YO!
BAU BAU!
Just give me Hongo!
Fuwawa ni suru!
Mococo ni suru!
Koyori ni suru!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!
All three!
Minna ga ii.
BAU BAU!
But!
Not coyori.
Not coyori?
What?
No!
FUWAMOCO-chan kasamaretai.
Are you gonna be in between FUWAMOCO?
No, you're a dog!
You're a dog!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Mococo!
Let's say it one more time.
Koyori-senpai.
What do you like about Fuwawa?
What would you like?
FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, happy happy time!
Thank you very much.
No, thank you, Koyori-senpai!
Thank you, Koyori-senpai!
BAU BAU!
Next, let's take a look at our regular corners!
Let's go to the corner we always go to!
Yes!
First up!
Today, we have our... Doggie of the Day!
Yes!
It's today's Doggie of the Day!
It's today's... It's Moca!
Moca!
I'm kind of in the way here.
But Moca, Moca's no longer a puppy.
So now Moca is learning to become a pro Frisbee player together with the Ruffians.
So cute!
Frisbee is also a way to become a pro.
Right now they're training.
Moca's doing their best.
Her face is so serious!
And her eyes are so cute!
Cute little black eyes and a nose!
FUWAMOCO Shiny!
Koyori-senpai, how do you think Mocha's BAU BAU?
How is Mocha's BAU BAU?
BAU BAU-chan?
BAU BAU teacher?
BAU BAU!
Moca wants to win!
Yeah!
I'm sure that's exactly it.
Zettai ni sonna BAU BAU.
Strong BAU BAU.
Yeah!
You know, you can tell Moca is doing their best.
They want to win the competition, but you know, they're still just... just a little bit...
I'm a puppy, so... Yeah, they're gonna do their best together with their Ruffians!
And let's all cheer on Moco!
Hopefully one day we can see them win that frisbee competition!
BAU BAU!
Oh!
Today I went on a walk!
You know some, Fuwa!
Oh!
A beach!
I went to the beach!
You went to the beach with a friend!
So nice!
Small house is so cute!
Right!
Really cute!
Koyari-senpai, do you like to go to the beach?
So-so.
I'm surprised.
Chotto igai desu.
I wanna see the cute girls in the beach.
Bikini girl gumi-san janai kana?
Bikini girl is so good.
So good!
The sea is so hot.
The beach is hot.
Maybe we can go to the beach together one day.
Issho ni beach toka wa... How deshita?
I want to go!
You know do the thing on the beach where you run?
The couples, the couples do it and they're like, catch me!
Oh, I fell in the water!
Umi ni ne, pasha pasha!
FUWAMOCO-ya beach episode!
Yeah, FUWAMOCO-ya beach episode, ne?
We're glad that you had a nice beach walk.
BAU BAU!
And today for our Question of the Day, the day!
Today's question is... Question for a special guest, Konyari!
Excuse my passion Japanese, I try my best.
I'll do my best with passion Japanese.
Konyari and FUWAMOCO often play together.
Konyari, do you like FUWAMOCO?
I don't want to choose.
I can't choose.
First love point.
You're so cute!
Is that my voice?
Yeah, voice!
Kerokero voice!
Love.
And?
Moco-chan's frog voice.
Yeah!
FUWAMOCO-chan is never give up hard too.
Yeah, I never give up too.
Yes, right.
Ganbarteru.
Tottemo.
Very very ganbaru.
I see FUWAMOCO-chan.
I do my best.
Wow, thank you!
Koyori-senpai sees FUWAMOCO doing her best and Koyori-senpai wants to wick her too.
But!
That's not fair!
Zurui!
FUWAMOCO mo!
You wanted to say the FUWAMOCO no serifu datte!
Koyori-senpai no ne, sugoi ganbatteiru tokoro mite, FUWAMOCO mo shikkari to ne, ganbaranai to na to omoimasu.
What was that just now?
It's like we're influencing each other.
We're influencing each other.
Dogs run in a pack!
Dogs are happier when they have friends.
I guess that's why.
I think Fuwamoco-chan is my daughter.
We'd like to say a big thank you to all the Ruffians and Chushu-kun today too!
That, you know, shared the Doggie of the Day.
That works, you know.
And for all your questions too, FUWAMOCO Morning is something special we make all together with you and today with Koyori-chan.
It means so much to us.
Please, if you have any more submissions, let us know with the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
BAU BAU!
Time for my next dreams!
Koyori-senpai!
What are you doing for your next dream?
After tomorrow, Final Fantasy VII Rebirth.
Final Fantasy VII Rebirth?
Rebirth!
Is it fun?
Tanoshii desu ka?
It is very very fun.
Melting time.
Time just disappears when you're having fun.
I get it, yeah.
Good games are good.
Good luck with Final Fantasy 7.
BAU BAU.
FUWAMOCO Schedule!
Moco-chan has kinda turned a bit into a frog.
More than a dog.
There might be some changes.
There might be a few changes, but FUWAMOCO, we have the holo Dorokei 2024 event coming up.
Koyori-senpai, you'll be there too, right?
Yes!
I am keisatsu.
No, police!
Policeman!
You won't catch FUWAMOCO, right?
So we'll be all practicing for that.
So we hope you can catch it.
And especially on the big day of hololive K-2024.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Joshu-kun, everybody, for joining us today for a very special episode of FUWAMOCO Yo!
Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Koyurin-senpai, after FUWAMOCO Morning, you always say the name of the Ruffians.
Can we do that together?
Okay!
Our Pure!
BAU BAU!
Jonah Chuma!
Nenoy!
BAU BAU!
Nyang-nyang-nyang!
Tabula Miner Takon!
BAU BAU!
Moosie-sies!
Pegasus League.
BAU BAU!
Sighting.
Ayataka.
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian and Joshi-kun out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!
Another BAU BAU!